one of the most deceptively complicated
tasks of building a magic the Gathering
deck is constructing a Mana base
deceptively complicated in no small part
because it's not what people think about
when they think about their deck
particularly in EDH if somebody asks you
what's going on in your Prosper deck
you're not going to say I'm glad you
asked it's running 35 LS six two Mana
rocks and a s ring with an even blend of
21 black and 21 B symbols and an
approximately 15% tap land saturation
that would be strange and yet lands are
one of the most important parts of a
deck allowing it to do all of the things
that might give it identity and excite
the person who plays it lands are the
foundation upon which a deck is built
and as with construction a shaky
foundation will lead to a shaky deck now
the good news here is that I'm not
necessarily going to be asking you to
spend more time thinking about your
manabase in just a bit I'll be telling
you about a brand new tool I created in
collaboration with my brother a tool
that can be used to rapidly diagnose
issues with manabases and point to
possible solutions but first I want to
lay a bit more groundwork for why
manabases are hard just so that you have
an idea of the sorts of challenges this
tool will be trying to solve typically
the question of Mana bases begins with
the color symbol split which makes sense
at a limited event such as a pre-release
the most primordial of deck building
experiences most players will engage in
you're best served to build a 40 card
deck with 17 lands and however many
lands you need can only be fulfilled
with Basics the fundamentals are the
same between limited and EDH you need to
figure out a collection of lands that do
a decent job of allowing you to cast
your spells this will have to do with
how total symbol counts of different
colors compare but also how intense
symbol requirements are and how early
cards are expected to be needed a ball
lightning has the same total symbol
requirement as three shocks but those
two selections of cards apply very
different levels of Demand on a deck's
red Mana likewise counter spell has the
same Mana cost as master of pearl
Trident or counterbalance but it
generally applies less strain on a de
blue Mana since it's a reactive card
that will likely be played later in the
game if you want a video that focuses
more heavily on that Rebel Lily also
happened to release a two-part series
about lands this month and her Mana base
video does a good job discussing the
timing of different Mana values a link
to that is in the description the task
of symbol management exists in all
formats limited 60c card constructed and
EDH but when it comes to how this task
is accomplished things diverge whereas
in limited your task will generally be
to create the least bad Mana base you
can out of Basics and whatever
non-basics you were lucky you have to
get your hands on in EDH your options
will be a whole lot less well limited
dual lands can simply be put into your
deck and not just guildgates or gain one
lands a plethora of different
highquality fixing lands are available
from Pain lands to fetches to triumphs
and Beyond the available fixing is so
good in fact that EDH techs often
includes some number of lands which are
lackluster in their color producing
abilities instead played for other
benefits they provide these are usually
called utility lands but how many of
these is it appropriate to play well I
actually like to think of land bases of
decks as existing to hit two different
goals one of these goals is covering a
deck's symbols lands exist to produce
the colors of Mana needed to cast a deck
spells the other goal of a land base is
covering total Mana values itself
assisted by hitting land drops hitting
your land drops consistently is
generally quite important to the success
of casual EDH decks more so than most
other formats in Magic so decks will be
best served to run enough lands to
consistently hit their land drops my
land Drop video is in the description if
you want to hear more about that okay so
we've got two goals to cover with this
one thing Our Deck lands one function of
utility lands then is to bridge gaps
between these two if a deck wants 37
lands for purposes of hitting its land
drops but only needs 33 lands to produce
an acceptable number of symbols to cast
its spells that leaves four slots for
colorless producing utility lands there
are more factors at play here that we'll
get into a bit later but this is a
simplified version of things okay so
with that background out of the way
we're ready to talk about the tool
before I get into that though this tool
Took a ton of effort to make and it's
available for free so let's talk about
my sleeves all of my decks are in Dragon
shield sleeves have been so for at least
a year now and the durability on these
is really a GameChanger back several
years ago when my playgroup played with
a collective deck pool sleeved up in a
different brand I was Infamous for
constantly breaking sleeves with my
thorough and heavy-handed shuffling in
Dragon Shields though this isn't a
problem at all I rarely break sleeves
even shuffling like this they also have
a fantastically wide array of different
color options there's this offensively
saturated magenta that I keep my liasa
deck in there's this lovely copper color
that I keep my malford deck in and then
there's this peach color that I keep my
rck in and these ones in particular are
also dual mats so they have a dark
background and this goes especially well
with things like extended art cards and
alars such as this one big thanks to
Dragon shield for supporting the channel
and you can check them out next time
you're looking to buy some sleeves all
right so the motivation behind this tool
is basically that there are a ton of
unique ways to screw up a Mana base poor
color pip distribution inadequate
overall Pips too many tap lands for a
deck's intended play pattern not enough
overall lands and so on for any given
dual land cycle there will often be some
decks where they'll work well and others
where they'll work poorly and some decks
will require more non-basic fixing than
others with this in mind I had a vision
for a tool in the months following my L
video last year a tool that could
quickly identify potential issues with
the de Mana base and offer suggestions
for improvement this idea sat around on
my to-do at some point list for a few
months before I decided that it just
wasn't going to get done and that I
should pawn it off on my brother Ian who
helped me with the coding on some of my
previous calculators on my website since
this was his work I'll have him go into
the basic guts of this thing hi I'm Ian
and I'm the one who built this thing to
understand how well a manabase functions
we want to model how it will perform in
game fully simulating commander games is
beyond the scope of this project so
instead we need to simplify it into a
form that we know we can work with my
other calculators used a hypergeometric
distribution which is a fancy sounding
name for some fancy looking math that
gives us exactly what we're looking for
if we're drawing a certain number of
cards from a deck with a certain number
of cards of a given category it will
tell us the exact odds of drawing a
certain number of cards of that category
if we calculate this for every possible
number of that type we could draw we
will get every possible outcome and its
probability on its own this only tells
us about one category but we can get
more while working on the last batch of
calculators I came up with a way to
calculate the odds for every possible
combination of multiple categories using
a branching tree like structure so if we
can sort all the lands in a deck into a
set of categories we can use this to
find every combination of lands that we
can draw and then check whether they let
us cast all our spells there are plenty
of ways we could come up with these
categories but I decided to just have
one category for each possible
combination of the five colors giving us
a total of 32 this is also the number of
unique values that can be represented by
five bits which means that if we number
those categories just right the bits
that store the number for each category
will also store the combination of
colors its lands can produce if we're
willing to get our hands dirty with some
bit level operations we can get a ton of
mileage out of these these categories
this is ultimately how we determine if a
set of lands can cast a spell but that
process is a little too complicated to
explain here if we test every
combination of lands to see if they can
cast a spell we can get a probability
for how often a given number of lands
will be able to cast a given spell by
running this for different numbers of
lands we can get an idea of how many
lands we need to cast the spell and by
factoring in the land count of the deck
we can figure out when we will draw
those lands this lets us determine how
often we can cast a spell on curve and
how much time we spend waiting for the
right lands to cast it if we do this for
all the spells in the deck and average
the results we can get an overall
representation of how well a deck's
manabase can cast its spells once we
have a way to score a manabase like this
we can test out small changes to find
the best way to improve it so this is
the backbone of the tool average
delaying casting spells is The Benchmark
here that is used to judge decks
alongside cast rate which here means How
likely it is that a card will be
castable on a turn on or before its Mana
value the tool also tests small changes
in the deck seeing how it is changed by
adding a single Basic Land for each type
among the next colors as well as a
wastes this is helpful for pointing out
which colors are most needed and the
inclusion of waste also gives insight
about how a deck's land count is looking
adding a waste to a deck shouldn't
really help it cast spells with less
delay or at least it should help a lot
less than adding something that actually
Taps four colors if adding a waste
reduces the average delay of a deck by a
substantial amount that's a good
indicator that it might need more lands
or at least that land count is a bigger
problem for it than color fixing as an
example here let's put my malagor deck
through this thing okay list pasted here
from architect Commander name here how
important is the commander I'd say it's
a nice bonus for a deck that is still
functional without it that selection
just tells the tool how heavily to wait
the Commander in its calculations since
some decks really care about whether
they can cast the commander whereas
other decks don't care nearly as much
such as this one load all that looks
good let's compute hm so this is
actually worse than I expected after
plugging in a discount for my one delve
card that cast rate is okay but not
amazing when we look at how improvements
affect it the amount that adding a waste
reduces the average delay is a little
bit on the high side this tool wouldn't
mind the deck having more lands probably
because it has a six B of Commander that
is still being weighted a bit higher
than other cards in the deck but it's
not terribly bad the swamp figure is
barely higher than the waist figure
which means that the deck is doing great
for black Mana no notes the red figure
on the other hand is a lot worse and
when I look at this deck I can kind of
see it there are 18 red symbols among
the lands and three among the Mana rocks
for a total of 21 which is an okay
figure but certainly not wildly High
what cards is this most likely to be a
problem for well I can tab over for that
this table shows the likelihood of
playing each card on curve the highest
delay here is the commander a six drop
with four symbols in its cost but what
about after that as you might expect
other double red cards Ox of aonis is a
card that will typically be getting cast
after malagor so later in the game the
turn five and this is likewise somewhat
true for fiery Confluence which is a
more reactive card however Glen horn
Buccaneer is a card that is more likely
to be wanted on curve and for that
reason it may be worth cutting given the
deck's very black centered manabase
immediately with this showcase a lot of
the assumptions of the tool become clear
there is an expectation that it is
desirable to play cards on curve I know
that ox aonis and fiery Confluence don't
need to be played on a turn equivalent
to their respective Mana values but the
tool doesn't know that while working
with Ian on dealing with edge cases I
briefly considered some sort of waiting
scheme involving card types so for
example instants are more often reactive
than other card types meaning that it
will be desirable to play an instant on
curve less often than it will be
desirable to play a creature or an
artifact on curve if we wanted to
maximize the accuracy of the model we
could add some sort of weight for this
like was done for the commander telling
the model to care some percent less
about instance for purposes of curve out
calculations however this gets it one of
the most challenging conflicts when it
comes to building a tool such as this
accuracy versus interpretability a model
that takes in more factors and adds more
weights will be able to produce results
that are more accurate but they also
make the model harder to understand
harder to pick apart harder to think
about model with too much unexplained
complexity becomes a black box this
users must be expected to blindly trust
and that's frankly an unreasonable thing
to ask no better to have an imperfect
but somewhat simpler model that people
can open the hood on so to speak and
check out the inner workings of before
deciding how they should be considering
its outputs this principle applies to
other aspects of the tool as well for
example I mentioned in my land count
video that draw can be used to find
additional lands this is true in
principle
but there are enough factors and caveats
present to make things more than a
little muddy for one as I mentioned in
that video higher costed draw must be
treated carefully in this regard a four
or five Mana draw spell shouldn't be
treated as a way to find lands in a deck
with 32 lands and six ramp spells since
in a decent portion of games you won't
even draw into enough lands to get there
without missing a land drop in the first
place a three Mana draw spell that
requires additional factors to be met
such as a large creature entering is
also tricky as it prompts a whole Suite
of different questions how often will
you have the creature how much does the
creature cost can you afford it are
there other downsides to playing it here
we run into both technical limitations
and interpretability limitations in
technical terms a more sophisticated
simulation that understands the text of
more cards and is willing to play
through more actions can figure out how
effective these sours of draw spells are
in finding lands but setting up and
running this sort of model is labor
intensive and computationally expensive
respectively
even if we solve the technical issues
getting into more complex cards
effectively requires that the simulation
make strategic decisions on behalf of a
hypothetical player and this fact
destroys the interpretability of the
results how are players supposed to know
the source of decisions that the model
is making on their behalf these
limitations lead to the implemented
solution here treating cards that might
help find lands as a portion of a land
this is what Frank carsten does in his
land count model though he excludes draw
spells of two Mana due to the
aforementioned complicating factors my
team ultimately decided not to include
any draw spells in the model not even
the lowcost ones and this was for a
couple reasons for one EDH doesn't have
the lowcost draw spell density that
other formats have Ponder has a 133%
play rate in EDH which certainly isn't
low but it's pretty meaker compared to a
format like Legacy where cantrips and
filtering often make up 10 to 20% of a
deck by volume in addition I don't even
know if it's necessarily appropriate to
assume that lowcost filtering spells are
being used to find lands in most cases
in formats with less forgiving Mulligan
rules they could fill that role by
necessity reasonably often but in EDH a
turn one Ponder could just as easily be
used to shuffle away a top three cards
containing two Lands still in most other
ways this model chose to take a similar
set of assumptions as ksten ramp is
effectively counted as a portion of a
land that can tap for colors
corresponding to whatever fixing the
specific card could provide with its
exact weight determined by how often a
deck will be able to cast it on curve
this in effect means that higher costed
ramp is weighted lower than lower costed
ramp particularly in decks with fewer
lands which intuitively makes sense to
me this solution misses a bit of nuance
in that a lot of decks play ramp to cast
cards ahead of curve but fully modeling
that would require an inordinate amount
of effort and has similar issues to
accounting for higher cost to draw it's
a good enough solution for the intent of
the tool though something that some
players might object to about the
presentation of the tool is the lack of
in your face Direction there are some
colors some vague pointers and numbers
provided about some specific cards but
not really any specific figures that are
set out as to what people should be
shooting for as far as overall manabase
quality goes this is a flaw in some ways
but it's a benefit in the sense that it
allows for the presence of a key guiding
hand in manabase construction risk
tolerance see different people will run
different numbers of lands and densities
of symbols depending on how comfortable
they are with the risk of getting Mana
screwed running a lower land count May
mean screw some games but it could also
result in more gas overall for somebody
deck building with the sole goal of
winning such as a cedh player it may be
worth it to run a land count that leads
to missing land drops and having stall
outs in some games if those downsides
are counterbalanced by more explosive
win potential at other points in time
meanwhile somebody just looking to have
a fun time might scoff at this approach
wanting a more consistent range of
experiences you utility lands follow a
similar principle running a higher
density of colorless producing utility
lands allows a player's lands to contain
more well utility but it also makes
casting spells more difficult how many
utility lands are correct it really
depends on how heavily you prioritize
the advantage of having abilities on
your lands and how much you're willing
to risk having trouble casting spells
this tool tries to avoid making
declarative statements on how
comfortable with risk players should be
but what it does do is try to make it
clear to players the sort of territory
they're looking in if you're running a
dangerously High number of utility lands
or a very slim land count I don't want
to be here to tell you not to do that
but what I do want to do is make sure
it's clear to you that that's what
you're doing so all that covers the
color considerations which is really the
heart of the model but there's also an
element that is quite relevant to all my
fellow budget Deck Builders out there
tap plans tap PLS are a little tricky
because they're related to a deck's
curve out and overall Mana base but in
very complicated ways that are ult to
have an algorithm sus out however it's
still a good thing for people to have
some data on and to cover how we
integrated it I'll hand things back over
to Ian one of the main compromises we
made with the color calculator was that
we had it ignore whether lands enter
tapped to compensate for this we can
make a second model that calculates for
this while ignoring Mana colors to start
we need to know how often our lands
enter tapped especially the ones that
only enter untapped under certain
conditions none of these conditions are
too complicated ated so we can write a
few simple algorithms to see how often
they enter tapped now we need to know
what impact that will have on our deck
which we can do by simulating the
opening turns using a heavily simplified
simulation we can look at the first
several turns of thousands of games and
score them based on how many spells we
can cast then we can run this two more
times once with no tap lands and once
with one less tap land this tells us the
overall impact of tap lands on on the
deck along with the Improvement we can
get from replacing one of them with a
land that enters untapped part of the
idea here was to make it clear how often
a land would enter tapped for a player
so for example with something like a cck
land you'd need specific basic typed
lands with a Tango land you'd need a
decent density of actual basic lands and
so on including a summary of how often
these will enter tapped can help players
double check that the budget dual lands
they're adding are actually going to be
working well for them building Commander
decks is complicated and it's pretty
easy to throw in Staples or personal
favorites absent-mindedly without
double-checking every single one this
isn't even just an issue of budget dual
Cycles there are an increasing number of
utility lands with some sort of check
involved which includes two cycles
originally printed in thron ofel drain
as well as a recent cycle of lands
printed in modern Horizons 3 while the
TA status of these lands isn't as
important as that of a Mana only Land
one of these entering untapped 70% of
the time versus 40% of the time could
easily make the difference in whether or
not they're worth running this sort of
consideration also goes for lands with
requirements for Tapping For Colored
Mana the vergers printed in dusk MN
aren't terribly problematic if they're
not online but there's a different cycle
that is much more problematic in my mind
tainted lands these aren't strictly
terrible they always enter untapped and
they might have a decently High chance
to tap for colored Mana in a lot of
decks I run one in my malagor deck and
it feels pretty good there however in
the context of EDH they really only make
sense in Black heavy two color decks
with a swamp count below the mid- teens
they won't be reliable in their colored
production one tricky thing with this
sort of analysis is once again the
assumptions the best example of this is
with a type of land that I tend to be
less of a fan of compared to a lot of
players slow lands or dual lands that
enter tapped unless a player controls
two or more other lands the tool loves
these when I throw my rat deck into the
tool and check the odds of having lands
tapped in the first five turns of the
game we get a 15.3% chance for cinder
Glade a 14.7% chance for copper line
Gorge a 99.1% chance for game Trail and
a frankly absurdly low 1.5% chance for
Rockall Veil even for a deck with a
lower land count the percent chance to
enter the battlefield tapped is still
quite low now I'm not saying that slow
lands are bad they're better than a lot
of types of budget dual land out there
but they're not 10 times better than
other types of lands this comes down to
the Nuance that is missed by the percent
of time tapped statistic all the play
testing algorithm cares about is whether
or not it has two other lands to play
play before the slow land what if those
lands are a different type of
conditionally tapped lands with a
different condition what if the other
lands are the wrong color what if one of
them is a shadow more filter that needs
an oncolor Mana to get working all of
these are cases where the slow land
contributes to the malfunctioning of the
Mana base before turn three but they're
considered successes due to the nature
of the percent of time tapped metric one
solution to this could be using a more
complex statistic than percent of time
tapped that takes more factors into
account but Who's That Knocking
that's right it's our old friend
interpretability percent of time tapped
is simply Leaps and Bounds more
understandable than any replacement
statistic I could come up with and for
that reason it's worth taking the L on
cases such as this so that's basically
the tool there are a couple extra
caveats one of which is that this tool
is naturally going to work better for
EDH Decks that are closer in structure
to most 60 card decks a lot of the
structure for the model was based off
the work of Frank ksten who himself
modeled much of his work on land counts
off of data captur from 60 card formats
this data can be adapted to EDH but it's
naturally still not going to fully
summarize some EDH specific types of
decks on that note this tool also works
just fine for 60 card decks even as it
was made with the complexities of
commander in mind so any 60 card format
players out there can just ignore the
Commander stuff and use this normally
the other potentially related caveat is
that this tool is going to be less and
less helpful the more ramp and land
focused a deck is Lands decks as an
archetype obviously aren't going to be
particularly well captured Ed by this
nor are Decks that heavily employ ramp
to get a specific curve out such as my R
deck likewise Decks that specifically
avoid paying for the costs of cards in
their deck such as a reanimator deck or
a peros bronze-blooded deck will
likewise not be well served by this tool
we certainly tried to offer some ways to
adapt this tool to these sorts of decks
which included a Band-Aid solution of
allowing users to exclude cards from the
analysis this makes a lot of problems go
away in principle without necessarily
solving them ultimately I'm relatively
with that compromise because at the end
of the day the people doing creative
curve outs with strange tools aren't
necessarily the ones this tool is
intended for me and Ian will likely work
on building an advanced version over the
next month or so with some extra factors
and heris built in for people who want
more control because the audience for
that does exist it's just not the
primary one we're trying to cater to no
this tool is ultimately intended for the
people trying to build a deck focused on
the ways nonland cards work together and
who just want a Mana base that doesn't
slow them down in that task I said in my
video a year ago that people should pay
more attention to their lands and in my
ramp video two months prior to that that
people should pay more attention to
their ramp but truly I understand why
people don't want to focus on these
things for a lot of decks these things
function more as obstacles between them
and a well-functioning deck than they do
as interesting tools to be utilized in
deck construction a lot of players feel
ambivalent at best about their Mana base
and at worst may feel actively resentful
of it a small but persistent minority of
comments I see on videos related to
lands Express something to the effect
that lands are a mistake the worst part
of Magic the Gathering and a thing to at
best be tolerated as the price of
playing the game whether or not lands
and Mana make for a fundamentally good
mechanic is outside the scope of this
video but for now I'll just say to these
people I see you I hear you and I want
to make your life a little easier the
gradual addition of analysis features to
deck building websites is already
helping in this task to some extent with
a website like archade you know have Pip
split multiple types of Mana curve a
hyper geometric calculator already
linked to the de categories and ways to
get more granular in analysis all at
your fingertips there will always be the
spikes out there who will crack open a
hybrid geometric calculator for their
different categories all on their own
but the expansion of these tools to be
more readily available and easy to use
is a good thing not just for the math-m
minded players but also for the players
who just want a deck that plays well
without needing to spend an extra hour
or two diving into the granular details
so this is a tool aimed principally at
those players and really anybody who
just wants a second set of eyes on their
Mana base something that can provide
immediate feedback and point to any
potential issues that may have been
missed if that sounds cool to you click
the link in the description that caps
off this video but there was a ton of
stuff that we couldn't talk about
relating to the tool I've recorded a
separate interview with Ian about those
things and it's over 20 minutes long I'm
going to give a couple previews of that
discussion here and if it seems cool to
you you can subscribe to my patreon for
$3 a month to gain access or just buy
access to that video in particular for
$2 if you don't don't want to add a new
subscription also on patreon I'm getting
back into producing a bonus video every
month in addition to my deck reviews and
I have a back catalog of more than a
dozen bonus videos that you can check
out that are a mixture of FaceCam videos
full length videos in my normal style
and endnotes for points that couldn't
quite fit into a public video you may
have also noticed the new background
color on this video and that was also
picked out by my patrons that's a whole
lot of great things about being a
celebri snail Patron if you ask me you
might even get your name in the credits
with that said here's a preview of my
extra discussion with the
information the only issue is that they
have a bit of documentation that says
hey please don't bombard me with a 100
cards at once so we had to come up with
our own solution and that solution is
named Clarence Clarence is a Raspberry
Pi with every card on scryfall
downloaded onto his system and so the
website sends requests for an entire
deck list to Clarence Clarence grabs
them all from his database puts it
together and sends it back to the user
so most of it is technically happening
on our servers what it does have is when
it sees a card that isn't in its
database it runs that by scryfall to
make sure that it's not a new card
that's been released in a new set but if
it is it'll download that to its own
database so it doesn't have to make that
check again so I decided to save myself
from some future effort so it constantly
keeps itself up to dat with all the new
cards because there are always new cards